Charlie it's Oh Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool hello I just want to do a
quick video today I wanted to tell you
about the paper that I'd be then thank
you
I doubt many of you actually know what
the bath Chronicle is but I live in bath
so my local paper teenagers fame on
YouTube I really don't like that picture
so yeah I just wanted to show you the
newspaper and tell you that I've been in
it I won't read you the article because
it's a little bit boring
um but yeah let me the paper and I'm on
page three as well I'm kinda on the
front but not right yeah I guess it's
pretty cool oh hi there coffee reading
by the Beatles 1962 to 1970 yeah I've
got a pretty good day I mean I kidnapped
charlie okay crimes a pretty cool thing
after me so again you get hooked on it
you get addicted to it it's just
brilliant I mean I woke up this morning
brush my teeth people and I oppose you
know another
oh yeah
which is where all the good new and
other which is where okay move get out
shop boo let's go about this I have
managed to hijack charlie is so good
let's use your back out ah now you can
say talk about you can say YUM I woke up
and brush my teeth I don't know have to
thank me thank say now